hey youtubers it's Charlie I hope you
all enjoyed the Game of Thrones season 4
premiere we'd all been waiting for so
long Peter Dinklage Piko just read the
phone book for 54 minutes and we would
have been satisfied so this is what I'm
gonna do this video will be a review
with my top 5 moments and the first
round of the giveaway if you're finding
me for the first time I'm just doing a
weekly giveaway all you have to do to
participate is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video
announce the winner in my Q&A video
tomorrow so there's more details in the
video I just posted earlier today the
season 3 video so you can check that -
just to get the rules and all that also
say please don't post any pirate links
in the comments I'd like to be able to
work with HBO someday and apparently
they don't like pirates so let's get
started here are my top 5 moments from
the episode careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet but number 5 the
melting down of ice notice I didn't say
the forging of Oathkeeper and widow's
wail this was all about calling back to
Ned Stark and all the other Starks who
have fallen the shot started on the
sheath which was made of a wolf's pelt
you know it was actually pretty
heartbreaking way to start the new
season the music was even really sad
with Tywin just haunting the forge with
his gaze I was actually kind of proud of
Jaime for defying him in that next scene
especially after he tried to give both
keep her back the show does an amazing
job of using visual cues to call back to
earlier moments you know like Ned
Stark's beheading george RR martin of
course writes a lot of them into the
story himself but it's up to the show to
interpret those visually and the whole
fort scene was just amazing if you want
to read that chapter from the books its
book 3 chapter 32 if you want to know
more about those blades that were being
forged like Tywin said only three people
know how to work fully reinstall and
toboe Motte the Smith is the best iswas
Ned Stark's Valyrian blade and when he
melted down toboe actually added this
reddish black hue to it for Lannister
colors so the two new blades actually
looked like they belonged to the
Lannisters number 4 Oberyn Martell
whorehouse introduction a nice callback
to Tyrion Lannister's introduction in
season 1 it wouldn't be Game of Thrones
if there weren't a scene in a whorehouse
take off your clothes
we're gonna be here a while I just love
the way that Tyrion shook his head
whenever Oberyn offered him a spot in
his sex party the culture in Dorne is
just a little bit different from that in
King's Landing you know
have more social standing and being
bisexual like Oberyn isn't a really big
deal you know like it is in the rest of
Westeros as funny as the Tyrion
introduction was their conversation
about his secret mission
to you know kill the mountain is really
what's going to drive that character
forward this season notice that he
dropped some epic knowledge on us about
Liana start to remember he said Rhaegar
left Elia for another woman and it
started a war that was Ned Stark's
sister Lyanna a lot of people myself
included think that Rhaegar and Lyanna
are Jon Snow's real parents and Ned
Stark just hid it from everyone to
protect John thematically it just kind
of makes a song of ice and fire about a
son of Ice and Fire it's just a theory
but it's one of the best I've seen if
you want to read that Oberyn chapter
from the books though it's Storm of
Swords chapter 38 number three Jaime
gets his golden hand it was so hilarious
how he just kind of waved goodbye the
hand itself is just one of the really
iconic set pieces like both keeper or
needle but in reality it's just as
useless as he claims you know a hook
really would be more practical it seems
like they're combining a lot of Jaime's
later chapters from book three with
what's happening right now just because
he came back to King's Landing so much
earlier and it's implied that you know
seriously is not down for twincest
anymore because she's so fried from
everything that happens in season two
but there is that one really notable
scene from Storm of Swords chapter 62 if
you want to know what it is just read
the chapter if not then don't worry
about it but it's fairly iconic so I
hope they end up doing it later in the
season number 2 Daenerys and her lapdogs
Drogo is sitting there purring in her
lap is just really cute but remember
these are untamable dragons the computer
graphics has also evolved a lot since
last year it really gives this feeling
of drogon thinking of himself as like a
big dog that's still like a little lap
dog you know he even snapped at her like
a hungry dog would whenever she tried to
slow down his feeding if he's gotten
this big in this short amount of time
imagine what its gonna look like in
another year dragons that aren't kept in
captivity will just keep on growing as
for the quantity and quality of dragon
scenes this was just the first episode
so I don't expect them to blow their
whole CG dragon budget right away I'm
really looking forward to seeing if you
you know drogue on action scenes like
they've teased in the trailer
the bigger ones that look on Serge auras
face as he's staring at drogon while all
this is happening tells you everything
you need to know this will not end well
for anyone in a battle between nature
versus nurture when you're talking about
dragons nature will always win if you
want to read this Danny you know outside
marine chapter from the books at storm
soars chapter 57 and my number one
moment
Aria takes back needle with the way they
rode out of there you think that the
whole world is on fire it's like Aria is
becoming a demon and she's descending
into hell smiling no less did you see
how much she smiled as she slowly
slipped needle into polliver said she
killed the other two Lannister men the
same way now with the giant hack just
she very gently massaged the blades into
them she just be quiet and die best line
of the episode hands down was fine
little blade maybe I'll pick my teeth
with it it was actually a really notable
change from the books here in Storm of
Swords at the crossroads whenever she
did get needle back The Hound ends up
being mortally wounded and she just
leaves him for dead so since they're
still writing together and in good
health we'll have to see if they split
them up anytime soon but personally I
don't mind them changing things just a
little bit there's so much fun together
don't you just feel like it's Arya
leading him around giving orders and not
the other way around if you want to read
that crossroads scene from the books
it's Storm of Swords chapter 74 so that
kind of gives you an idea of how much
they're jumping around in time because
we went all the way from like late 30s
and now we're up in the 70s so they're
really just picking things to make it
more linear and as one last bonus moment
we have to talk about the fens this is
actually a bit of a WTF moment but I'd
actually thought that Joseph's gap was
playing the Magnar then but it looks
like they cast someone else in the role
more to that WTF moment though who else
said that line from seven in their head
whenever they threw that bag down at the
fire what's in the bag what's in the bag
yep cannibals all I could think about
was ye olde Hannibal Lecter's cooking
blog I can't remember but up to this
point in the story I don't think we've
seen actual cannibalism occur on the
show you know unless you count the
whites and they don't really eat people
they just chop them up but now it's your
turn let me know what was your favorite
moment from the premiere was it meeting
Oberyn for the first time was it
Daenerys inner dragons or did you just
think it was really awesome that they
included that sirdon't Oh scene with
Sansa that was
yeah really a small moment from the book
so I'm surprised they included it but it
was really cool they really are like way
too many awesome things that we could
talk about from this episode so feel
free to add stuff in the comments if I
didn't mention it in the video overall I
rated the episode is a solid a-minus
I have to save the coveted a for the
biggest and best episodes this season
but as first episodes go I loved it way
better than season 3 episode 1 the humor
was amazing just a lot of really subtle
additions from the actors like tyrion
just shaking his head and Nikolaj
coster-waldau just shaking his golden
hand goodbye one of the big reasons why
the show is so good is because the
actors are so good I'll say that my
favorite character from the episode
though was definitely Oberyn it's gonna
be so much fun
he's like a wild rock star on vacation
and Kings Landing is the hotel that he's
gonna trash and then it was that line
tell your father the Lannisters aren't
the only ones who pay their debts so
good I could talk about it all day
but let me know what are your final
thoughts in the episode you know was
there anything that you didn't like in
it
in other news like I said I'll be
posting the Q&A video tomorrow we're all
announced the giveaway winner you can
click here to get that video add the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here for all my other season 4
videos thank you so much for watching
this is going to be such an amazing
season high fives everyone I'll see you
tomorrow
you